avec nous le dirigeant et fondateur des
x démotion benoît d'antan bonjour
bonjour
alors xd moshen existe depuis combien de
temps là bas ça fait onze ans maintenant
que la société a été créée alors comment
ça s'est passé la création et puis
comment a évolué cette société cette
création s'est passé ici à coignières
donc dans ces mille mètres carrés que
nous avons commencé avec juste cinquante
ou soixante mètres carrés d'utilisation
et aujourd'hui on est complètement fou
l'on verra tout à l'heure comment on est
en train de s'agrandir
becqueter 11 ans d'expérience de
services donc beaucoup d'événements
coupe du monde jeux olympiques événement
exceptionnel concert stade de france
bercy beaucoup beaucoup de choses qui se
passaient y compris dans le département
donc on est assez heureux de pouvoir
continuer pendant cette période
difficile à travailler autant la reprise
a été bonne donc une formidable équipe
qui continue à rayonner dans le monde
est là le dernier plus gros projets dont
sur lequel les équipes ont travaillé
c'est l'exposition universelle de dubaï
très rapidement un un mot sur la manière
dont vous avez traversé la crise
sanitaire alors en fait la crise
sanitaire grâce à la robotisation et
tous les systèmes qui aujourd'hui se
passe en distance un tout le monde a dit
sensations que vous savez tout le monde
fait des conférences aujourd'hui tine
zoom et dans le fonctionnement à
distance nous c'est la même chose au
niveau broadcast de plus en plus
d'outils technologiques de ce mode là
sont utilisés et grâce à cela beaucoup
d'entreprises ont eu besoin de
communiquer avec cette robotisation à
distance et donc nous ont commandé du
matériel un mot sur justement
l'évolution technologique vous en parler
du nouveau matériel je suppose il y
trônent des toutes les caméras qui aussi
qui évolue alors en fait la grosse
évolution aujourd'hui qu'il est en train
de se passer c'est la remote production
donc principalement aujourd'hui on
télécommande à distance les systèmes par
la fibre optique mais maintenant plus
récemment et grâce au consortium qui est
en train de se mettre en place avec le
vélodrome de saint quentin 5 g nokia et
tous les partenaires de france tv lab et
le vélodrome directement en fait on à
l'utilisation maintenant de la 5g pour
pouvoir piloter à distance nos systèmes
nous ça c'est la grosse évolution qui
est en préparation on reviendra dessus
pour les jo de paris 2024 en mousse en
maintenant les jeux olympiques de paris
2024 c'est une véritable opportunité
pour votre société c'est extraordinaire
mois depuis maintenant les jeux
d'albertville donc ça remonte quand même
en 92
les effectivement les jeux olympiques
d'athènes en 2004 aujourd'hui on les a
tous couverts on part on vient de finir
tokyo avec tous les drones qui ont été
qui ont été utilisés là bas sur place et
en chine on nous allons tourner tout les
sports extrêmes avec nos technologies
cablecom juste une précision à la chine
c'est parce qu'il ya les jeux olympiques
d'hiver 2022 c'est ça exactement donc là
en fait on vient de terminer tokyo l'été
2021 et nous partons donc avec l'année
de décalage donc au vide sur 2022 en
chine et on prépara dans la foulée paris
2024 en france avec quatre sites
olympiques comme vous savez sur le
département et donc on travaille
énormément en ce moment que la
préparation de ces jeux nous avons lancé
du cio champion s league dont les tests
ont été faits au vélodrome en
avant-première donc c'était extrêmement
important de avec cette rencontre
guillaume séraphine et bruce du
vélodrome pour lequel on a réalisé ces
essais et c'est je dirais les prémices
de ce qui va être utilisé par la suite
sur paris 2024 est-ce que vous pouvez
nous décrire justement les images qu'on
voit là de cette démonstration alors
cette démonstration a eu lieu qu'en
novembre donc juste avant de partir sur
la première événement la première
session à palma là ce que vous voyez
c'est la grande vitesse de déplacement
du ce qu'on appelle le xliv un des
câbles calmes sur lequel nous avons
rajouté l'arrêté augmente et donc je
vous expliquais les tendances du marché
et de son évolution donc la remote
production et la réalité augmentée donc
tous les graphismes virtuel qui vient
d'être ajouté que vous allez que vous
vous allez bientôt voir en live sur la
prochaine épreuve qui va avoir lieu en
lituanie et on espère très prochainement
l'année prochaine en 2022 au vélodrome
en ce moment même vous faites des essais
dans votre xd motion lab wii le wii
motion lab mais xd motion lab en fait
les moteurs de jeu riehl qui sont
utilisés dans le monde entier ont d lab
qui permettent aux je dirais à tous les
ingénieurs de pouvoir développer ces
technologies donc on a décidé d'ouvrir
ce lab pour que je dirais tous nos
clients puissent venir voir notre
technologie vous pouvez prendre un
rendez-vous à avoir une visualisation en
direct en live de cette technologie la
grâce à cela ben c'est un échange d'une
communauté d'ingénieurs qui permet de
faire évoluer la technologie et bien
benoît d'antan on voit tout de suite
vous transférez dans ce x10 motion lab
en réalité augmentée c'est parti là bas
je me tais les portes
vous êtes maintenant chez xd motion lab
le principe en fait c'est d'utiliser
donc ce nouveau robot six axes qui est
équipé d'une caméra haute définition
cette caméra donc est relié sur le bras
en mouvement et permet en fait grâce à
ce fonds vert de pouvoir faire de la
production virtuelle
aujourd'hui nous utilisons donc des
jeunes jean 3d sur base d'une ville qui
s'appelle pic ce top avec nos amis et
collègues de postes logique qui sont
vraiment les professionnels de cette
techno là
en deux mots toute la réalité augmentée
fonctionne grâce à ce type de
technologie aujourd'hui qui est de
remplacer le monde réel par le monde
virtuel et de mixer les deux
technologies donc ce bras est à la fois
très souple et silencieux il se déplace
donc dans l'est
trois dimensions et à la faculté des
pouvoirs aussi gérer des points de vue
très spécifique en mouvement et très
précis et comme vous pouvez le voir
derrière moi la scène virtuelle est
totalement traquer et liés à ce type de
mouvements en trois dimensions donc on a
véritablement cette capacité
technologique de pouvoir travailler
aussi en remote production c'est à dire
que le robot étant complètement
opérationnels en ip on peut
véritablement aujourd'hui le
télécommandée à distance à des milliers
de kilomètres grâce à la fibre ou même
grâce dans le consortium aujourd'hui de
la 5g au vélodrome de saint quentin
avoir la capacité de piloter ce robot en
5 g grâce à des puces aujourd'hui qui
sont opérationnels et nos partenaires de
nokia qui travaille avec france tv lab
sur ce type de techno donc aujourd'hui
une révolution est en marche la
robotique avec des caméras ptz et
pilotage par notre logiciel à ubot
permet d'aller jusqu'à des dizaines de
caméras pilotés à distance et donc
d'utiliser que ce soit en corporate pour
les entreprises en tv broadcast sur le
bord d'un terrain comme ceux sur ce que
l'on tourne aussi sur les six nations du
rugby du stade de france où les jeux
olympiques ce type de technologie